quem de vocês já pedalou bastante gente
então vocês devem lembrar da sensação de
vento no rosto
talvez a primeira volta na quadra
aquele passeio no parque
aquele passeio na praia aquela corrida
postada na rua
tem gente que acha que a bicicleta é uma
atividade individual
na verdade muita gente pratica a
bicicleta em grupo e ela me permitiu
conhecer muitos lugares bacanas
muitas pessoas interessantes pessoas
muito diferentes de diferentes níveis
sociais diferentes níveis culturais e
todos compartilhando o mesmo prazer de
pedalar
alguns mais ativamente em busca de
ciclovias e e meios de transporte outros
pelo lazer e alguns pela atividade
física pela saúde mas sem dúvida pessoas
muito interessantes mas vamos deixar a
bicicleta um pouco de lado e vamos falar
sobre exclusão
quem já não teve uma experiência de
exclusão
quem não lembra a sensação de ser o
último convidado de um time por jogar
mal o sport quem não lembra a sensação
de não ter sido convidado para uma festa
por não conhecer muito bem o organizador
a sensação de não poder num restaurante
por não ter dinheiro de não ter feito
aquela viagem de ter sido excluído do
grupo na escola no trabalho
agora imaginem se todos os dias da vida
nós acordássemos e não pudéssemos olhar
à luz por ser cego se todos os dias a
gente quisesse pegar um objeto uma
simples ação de pegar um objeto que não
pudessem porque os braços paralisados
se a gente precisasse subir uma escada
que não pudesse pôr está preso numa
cadeira de rodas
essa é a realidade de muita gente e
quando a gente pensa e empático se
colocando no lugar dessas pessoas
talvez as nossas sensações de exclusão
se tornem menores se tornem um pouco
mais insignificantes mas a gente começa
a pensar legal esse é uma situação que
existe é um problema que existe mas o
que eu posso fazer é um problema
político social é da sociedade como um
todo que eu posso fazer
e quando eu me perguntava eu
invariavelmente chegava num ponto em que
eu me questionava em que momento eu
deixei de fazer parte da sociedade como
um todo se é um problema da sociedade
eu tenho que ajudar a tratar e buscando
formas e pensando em maneiras chegou
chegando à conclusão de que cada um tem
uma forma de ajudar diferente eu posso
ajudar
de acordo com o meu nível financeiro de
acordo com a minha experiência de vida
de acordo com a minha profissão eu tenho
diferentes maneiras de ajudar as pessoas
que têm necessidades junto com alguns
amigos que pedalam nós
vamos com vontade de levar essa
experiência do pedal para as pessoas que
não tinham condições algumas delas que
nunca pedalou por ser cego de nascença e
outros que ficaram cegos no decorrer da
vida e que acharam que nunca mais
poderiam pedalar mas cada deficiência
tem a sua particularidade
eu não posso tratar uma pessoa da
cadeira de rodas da mesma maneira é uma
pessoa que tenha só é é paralisia uma
pessoa que tenha tetraplegia uma pessoa
que é cega de uma pessoa que não tem
capacidade de equilíbrio e através das
diferentes maneiras nós fomos procurando
diferentes formas de ajudar em 2016 no
começo de 2016
nós encontramos uma possibilidade de
levar pessoas com deficiência visual
para o pedal
reparem encontramos uma maneira de levar
pessoas com deficiência visual para o
pedal
o nosso objetivo não era levar o pedal
para as pessoas com deficiência visual é
muito simples eu pegar o ciclismo e
levar para um grupo de cegos pedaladas
não era o que a gente queria
o que a gente queria era trazer os cegos
para o ciclismo era fazer efetivamente
uma inclusão e qual não é a grandeza que
quando a gente começa a fazer esse
trabalho a inclusão ela se dá dos dois
lados
ela se dá no cego no ciclismo e nos
ciclistas com essa deficiência
nós encontramos a bicicleta de dois
lugares e através delas nós vimos a
possibilidade de pedalar com deficientes
visuais
encontramos na associação de cegos do
rio grande do sul um parceiro para fazer
esse projeto em junho do ano passado
fizemos o primeiro evento do pedal da
inclusão
naquele momento foram 100 ciclistas
sendo que 20 deles eram deficientes
mas e as reações é foram as mais
variadas da pessoa que chegava e queria
ver a bicicleta tocar na bicicleta sente
cada pedaço da bicicleta
as pessoas queriam sem parar na
ansiedade de ter aquele prazer pela
primeira vez e uma das pessoas
passeio vinha decorrendo paramos em
algumas sinaleiras
num desses momentos um dos cegos atende
o telefone e diz mãe eu não posso falar
agora estou pedalando desliga e começa a
dar risada sem parar
a mãe não entendeu nada
eu nunca pedalei é essa sensação é
espetacular a sensação de estar
proporcionando isso uma pessoa que nunca
pedalou é espetacular
da mesma forma que ele que nunca tinha
pedalado uma outra menina que já havia
pedalado descreveu como é um pássaro de
asas quebradas que volta a voar
essa é a sensação que ela estava tendo
naquele momento
o projeto foi
crescendo ea gente foi buscando outras
formas de trabalhar mas como todos sabem
é difícil é difícil arrecadar dinheiro é
difícil conseguir parcerias para
trabalhar com esse tipo de ação e nós
buscamos através de outras formas de
bicicleta através de outras formas de
inclusão trazer muita gente nesse nesse
processo
aqui tem um outro exemplo de bicicleta
um exemplo que nós estamos trabalhando
nesse ano
o objetivo desta bicicleta naturalmente
trabalhar com pessoas com deficiência
motora
aqui na foto outro momento maravilhoso
ali apavorado sentados ou eu realmente
bem apavorado
a experiência de estar sentado numa
bicicleta sem ter o controle é algo
indescritível
quem está pedalando a lilica liga uma
pedagoga professora de uma escola
municipal de viamão uma turma de
crianças de 3 anos de idade e ela estava
guiando uma bicicleta pela primeira vez
eu era os olhos dela
eu estava com muito medo mas o sorriso
dela de estudo diz o que ela estava
sentindo nesse momento e como a gente
busca e tem tem uma outra parte do pedal
da inclusão que é de uma certa maneira
quando a gente fala em inclusão social
um pouco e relevante que a forma como
nós buscamos pra comprar essas
bicicletas tratam-se bicicletas caras
esse é um protótipo que foi construído
há outra bicicleta de dois lugares
também é muito cara
a gente encontrou na arrecadação de
tampinhas uma forma de coletar dinheiro
então através da também a gente trabalha
um outro caminho um outro viés
sustentabilidade ea solidariedade
através da arrecadação de tampinhas
essas tampinhas são revendidos
destinadas para o caminho certo
destinadas para reciclagem e as pessoas
de uma maneira muito simples conseguem
ajudar de uma certa forma
no ano passado nós doamos 11 bicicletas
para a associação de cegos
essas bicicletas hoje estão com a
associação são feitos pedais com uma
freqüência bimestral ou trimestral eles
organizam e saem e esse ano nós montamos
consolidamos o pedal da inclusão como
associação
estamos trabalhando para comprar as
nossas próprias bicicletas pra gente
poder levar o pedal da inclusão para
outras cidades
e isso já está acontecendo nós já temos
em são paulo pessoas que entraram em
contato conosco e querem levar o pedal
da inclusão para lá recebemos na semana
passada uma ligação de belém do pará de
pessoas querendo saber como podiam
ajudar mandando tampinhas é a corrente
do bem são as coisas acontecendo de uma
forma sem nem saber como esse foi o
primeiro pedal quando nós fizemos a
doação das bicicletas para a associação
e no dia seguinte eu recebi uma ligação
de um pai que viu a reportagem dizendo
ser pai de uma criança autista que não
teve a oportunidade de oferecer para seu
filho a experiência da bicicleta como eu
posso fazer leandro para ajudar vocês
para que os autistas possam andar de
bicicleta e nessa ligação a gente
começou a entender que é muito mais do
que cegos é muito mais do que autistas
tem que trabalhar com todos os tipos de
deficiência nós precisamos buscar todas
as formas de trazer deficientes
diferentes tipos para o pedal e é isso
que a gente vem buscando no ano passado
foram cegos
esse ano estamos trabalhando com
cadeirantes ea gente não tem a previsão
de pará através da coleta de uma
tampinha uma simples tampinha eu resigne
fiquei essa tampinha
pra mim isso aqui que vai pro lixo na
casa de muitas pessoas que vai pro lixo
em muitos restaurantes é um pedaço de
uma bicicleta
e você o que está fazendo para ajudar na
inclusão
obrigado
[Aplausos]